[Music]
all right news now i team with a story
you will only see right here on eight
news now an office manager accused of
embezzling hundreds of thousands of
dollars from not one not two but three
different dentists
and now one of those dentists telling
our david charns exactly what happened
and david apparently the suspect also
pleading to get out of jail as well yes
she was in the i-team the only ones in
court for her hearing today as daniel
powers asked that judge to release her
from jail pending trial the trial for
her first set of charges
we have spots to fill and it's so easy
to just interview someone and then put
them in the position
of trust dr debra staton put her trust
in her office manager danielle powers
our goal here at desert hills dental is
always make your dentistry affordable
that's powers in a video highlighting
the office desert hills dental on
facebook here's another photo as the
practice celebrates power's birthday she
was the most fabulous office manager
ever was because she's now charged with
embezzling hundreds of thousands of
dollars from the business although i had
too much trust within one person who
almost nearly sunk my ship evidence in
the criminal case includes this video
which prosecutors say shows powers
coming back into work and taking cash
left on her desk it's very hurtful it's
very hurtful the level of deceit is just
heart-wrenching after seeing the video
staton confronted her five-year employee
and fired her soon after police were on
powers trail again accusing her of
stealing thousands of dollars from a
second dental office this one on blue
diamond road according to court
documents that dentist became suspicious
when powers didn't want her photo on the
website and she objected to more front
desk staff coming on board that dentist
also saying powers told him she needed a
day off for the reading of her
grandmother's will but in reality powers
needed the time to go before a judge
yeah her grandmother has died several
times
that second dentist fired powers but
prosecutors say it didn't stop there she
then got a job working for this third
dentist on the east side court documents
saying she stole thousands from here too
were you surprised when you found out
this happened not only
a second time but now a third time
it's a hard crime to prosecute it's a
hard it's very hard for us to get
through the system legally police picked
up powers last week after she skipped
court in february in court tuesday she
asked a judge to release her from jail i
i've made some bad choices to get myself
here i agree to that the judge holding
her for now meantime stayton says this
all serves as a reminder to do your
homework especially when running your
own business
it's so important to do a background
check if anybody is going to be sitting
and counting your money
or dealing with money in the in the
office there should be a
thorough background check done have you
talked to her since no
no
i think about it once in a while but no
no i wouldn't have anything nice to say
dr staton also winning a civil case
against powers to get some of that money
back a judge setting a criminal trial
for august in that first case she has
pleaded not guilty i'm david charns live
local now